depuis le confinement et bien cette
salle elle est vide on ne peut plus
faire de nos activités habituelles
c'est vraiment désolant seuls les
scolaires peuvent encore faire du sport
finie la gym le badminton le yoga ou
bien encore les arts martiaux
pourtant ici habituellement tous les
jours entre 17h et 23h les activités
sportives s'enchaînent avec le
confinement tout s'est arrêtée depuis
septembre ce club de gym volontaire a vu
ses effectifs divisés par deux qui dit
moins d'adhérents 10 - de trésorerie
pour faire fonctionner la structure nous
avons treize animateurs sportifs en cdi
intermittent que nous allons que nous
mettons en chômage total après les
vacances de la toussaint puisque le
confinement nous empêche d'avoir tout
acte locaux pour les dirigeants de ces
clubs
il ne faut pas que la situation perdure
pour eux l'avenir est incertain
il se demande si les adhérents
reviendront donc s'amorcer problématique
mais c'est catastrophique parce que le
fait que nous adhérons n'ai pas pu avoir
de cours pendant quasiment six mois de
l'année compromet d'abord leur santé
compromet l'équilibré financier de nos
clubs
à terme si les gens ne reviennent pas et
si on ne peut pas avoir accès aux salles
un certain nombre de clubs vont
disparaître le président de la
république a annoncé ce mardi la reprise
du sport en club pour les mineurs en
décembre et la reconduction d'un fonds
d'urgence de 15 millions d'euros
destinés aux associations sportives
amateurs